[Music]
meanwhile more good times on late-night
TV up first in tonight's NOAA tell James
and Ariana's Titanic tributes playing
Jack and Rose their one take medley of
13 cover songs in under five minutes was
nearly as epic as the movie itself
[Music]
it's just the tip of the iceberg
tomorrow is her carpool karaoke where
Courtin wills belt out the ariana lyrics
he just memorized and we'll find out how
Grande's left hand the one with that
$93,000 engagement ring from Pete
Davidson wound up bandaged
well mr. Corden today is off to a wild
start next Nicky makes Colbert blush I
might Steven after the show he's gonna
come back to work with a magical glow
while flirting with her fave late night
hosts Minaj got censored multiple times
Nicki was promoting her new album Queen
and knew this stuff would make news she
plugged it on Instagram it's like top
three interviews of all time just
address me as Queen Nicki Colbert thing
is go bears take it he's been married to
wife Evelyn for nearly 25 years that's
news to Nicki are you married
and finally a Fallon Reynolds drinky
gamefails that's such a weak stomach I'm
not kidding Ryan did warn Jimmy this
week along with his wife Blake Lively
he's been promoting his gin company and
last night the Deadpool star played
drink Oh mixing his liquor with Twinkies
and grape soda
my child's diet but on Jimmy's turn
[Music]
that's the first thing I ever barked
when your own show all right no
[Music]